necroptosis is one type of cell death  which involves features of necrosis and  apoptosis and this is highly regulated  process it involves inflammatory  cytokine and thereby inflammation  overall which is very different from  apoptosis key features involves  regulated programmed cell death loss of  ATP swelling of the cell generation of  Ross release of lysosomal enzyme and  also unlike apoptosis necroptosis does  not involve caspase activation  necroptosis is found to be important  underlying acute tissue damage  myocardial infarction  ischemia mediated reperfusion injuries  and stroke  the molecular mechanism involves  tnf receptor one tlr3 or interferon  receptor signaling however the entire  molecular mechanism is not well  characterized  watch the full video to know more